well it's me it's my life it's my songs
and i'm revealing them to you on et
canada i'm dolly by the way yeah if
there's one name in music that brings
people together
from all walks of life it's our country
queen dolly parton
growing up in the smoky mountains of
tennessee dolly was one of 12
children and while her family had next
to nothing
she didn't let that stop her from
following her dreams of pursuing a
career
in music after more than 60 years in the
spotlight
dalia sold over 100 million records
worldwide
and earned 26 number one songs on the
billboard country charts
the biggest record held by any female
artist
and if that's not enough she even has
her very own amusement park
called dollywood now in addition to her
career on stage and
on screen dolly is known for her
philanthropic work
most recently donating one million
dollars to coronavirus research at
vanderbilt
university which was used to help fund
modernist vaccine
now over the years we've had the chance
to get to know the woman behind
the rhinestones the biggest hair highest
heels and
not to mention some of the most
successful songs in country music
so to celebrate dolly's milestone 75th
birthday on january 19th
we're looking back at some of our
favorite moments with the singer
and with all her success it's quite
clear she wouldn't be the woman she is
today
without staying true to what she values
most in life
faith family and love and for that we
will always love you dolly
dolly's musical legacy isn't the only
thing she's held on to over the past
six decades her signature style hasn't
changed with that platinum blonde wig
topping off her iconic look and back in
2012
dolly revealed how she stays grounded
even though she may look a little over
the top from the outside
i know i look totally artificial but i'd
like to think i'm totally real
where it counts you know seriously but i
don't you know i don't
uh i don't know anything else too big
except
me and so i think everybody should be
them whoever that is whatever that is
so it's not a problem for me to you know
to be real because i just don't try to
put on any
false pretenses other than piling it on
on the
[Music]
my
outside
now of course dolly's music is
recognized across
generations but it was whitney houston's
famous rendition of i will always love
you
that catapulted her into the global
spotlight
whitney's 1992 take on the song for the
bodyguard soundtrack
recently surpassed one billion views on
youtube
and dolly recently opened up to et
canada's ros weston
about turning down elvis presley's
request to cover the ballad
i know you were very protective of that
song you were very protective of the
rights
you wanted to withhold them elvis wanted
to do it you had to turn them down
because they wanted
rights to the song all those years ago
when you made those decisions do you
sort of thank yourself every now and
then when you look around
and see your life and what that one song
has done for you
i would have loved to have heard elvis
sing the song it was not
elvis it was colonel tom who's his
manager that
you know said they had to have half
deposition but i still think about elvis
saying that
so i i have mixed i have mixed emotions
about that
but i am so grateful that it has done so
well
and like i say that's money i can put
into my family fund rather than
elvis family i was never so flattered
enough lord in my life and when whitney
did that and the incredible job that she
did and the
great success of the bodyguard movie
[Music]
you know and it being still considered
like one of
the greatest love songs ever i take
great pride in that i'm very humbled by
it
but she did an incredible job on that
now back in 2017 we sat down with the
grammy winner for the release of her
46th studio album and first children's
album i believe in you
where she opened up about that one
project she never got around to
having kids of her own my husband and i
were married 50 years
a couple years ago and we thought at the
start we would have children we even had
names for them now but it never did work
out that way
and then you know how time goes by and
you think well
i think it was not meant for us to have
kids so everybody's kids could be mine
because if we'd have had children
i probably wouldn't have spent as much
time and effort you know with other
people's children because you know how
it is if you got your own
you gotta you know take care of them and
save the money for them and make sure
they're
so i think it worked out really well
it's a well-known fact that dolly and
her husband of nearly
60 years carl dean keep their
relationship extremely private
and have done so since the beginning
this could definitely be the key to
keeping their romance strong
after so many years or maybe it's those
romantic date nights in their rv
camper that keeps the spark alive i mean
that sounds like a country love song
right there we don't do a lot of just
date nights our whole life is kind of
like a sweet thing but we'll
on anniversaries or on his birthday or
mine we'll go out to eat
and you know he doesn't like to get out
in public that much
but we we have our little rv camper we
go and i often cook in the mornings
like on weekends i'll cook and we pack
up a picnic basket and we'll go out to
the country and
find a riverbank we'll have picnics and
that sort of thing yeah
now somebody told me that you actually
enjoy uh going through like a taco bell
drive through together is that true well
yeah we go through all the
drive-throughs together
in our little rv it doesn't have to be
taco bell but we like that but we like
all of them
we hit them all and back in 2016 dolly
opened up about her secret wedding with
carl yeah for those who don't know
dolly actually met carl at a local
laundromat on the same day
she moved to nashville the pair quickly
got used to keeping their love for each
other
private because dolly's record label
thought a serious relationship would get
in the way
of her music career but no surprise
dolly proved them all wrong and managed
to make both
a success we had gone across the state
line in tennessee because
or into ringgold georgia because the
record label i was with asked me to not
get married because they had invested a
lot of money that was in 1966
they said wait here because we got money
tied up and our individual career we
went that same weekend sneaked off
across the state line and got married
and then of course a year later the
record label
everything was going good i was happy at
home but they said see
if you would have got married this
problem would have been going i said
i've been married for a year
and not having kids of their very own
gave dolly even more time to spend with
her goddaughter miley cyrus
over the years the pair have found
several opportunities to collaborate
together
including her very special appearances
on hannah montana of aunt
dolly
girls i don't just rock i roll
she's like one of my kids i've known her
since she's tiny little baby
and i've always known she was so
talented so gifted
and i knew what she was going through
when she was trying to make her own way
after hannah montana
and you know she i've said she's going
to always land on her feet no matter how
high she jumps
and you know it's like she and she has
and she will and more recently
of course dolly had to have miley on her
latest album a holly dolly christmas
where the two teamed up on the original
track christmas is
she had to sing on this christmas album
she was working on her own project i
said
i'm not going to ask you to put it out
of the single i know you got your own
thing
but you have to sing on this album with
me you and billy ray because you're like
family and i'm never
probably going to ever do another
christmas album i said you have to just
sing on this song she said well okay
dolly
i'll do it ain't dolly